after you have a huge success like
Garden State the thing grossed about 30
40 million dollars at the box office am
I correct yeah you made it for what like
two million bucks we made it for
everyone and this is the story everybody
passed on so I was on Scrubs I get
Natalie Portman who who loves it and she
wants to be in it and I shop it around
town and I'm on a new hit show and I've
got Natalie Portman and I'm like wow
this is cool I'm gonna make a movie
right everybody on Town passes on it
every single person says no he went to
every Studio everywhere every Studio
every rich guy everyone with a phone and
a desk why do you think they passed on
it it wasn't a traditional screenplay it
didn't follow really all the rules you
know there's all this stuff about you
know three-act structure you know this
should be happening by this page and
right and I didn't follow any of that I
just wrote a cool what I thought was a
cool story and I thought and I wrote
about what I what I was feeling at the
time I was sort of depressed even though
I was successful I was in a depressed
place and and and why were you depressed
um I don't know I've battled depression
in my life and and if you have it comes
at a time sometimes when things things
are going really well so I wrote it
about that and everyone passed on and it
was about to fall apart and I met this
like sugar daddy who was in the morning
made a bunch of money in the mortgage
business right he wanted to get an
entertainment he didn't know anything
about it but he had a lot of capital to
spare he liked Natalie Portman he liked
me and he said anyone you know we were
our budget at the time was like six
million dollars but when a guy who's not
in the business who's just gonna aren't
you nervous as hell yeah but I had no
other option Howard I had like it was it
was about to not happen at all would you
say stuff do you like this is going to
make money right
yeah but he had he had lots of advisors
I mean he he was in the business but he
had lots of Talking Heads in his ear and
and and and so he said you know our
budget the time was six million dollars
and he goes look
like is there any way you can make this
movie for two and a half I mean we were
like
at the time we were like [__] I don't
know if we cut a lot of but I had
amazing producers and they figured it
out and we made this movie for in 25
days for two and a half million dollars
it's pretty amazing that he put up two
and a half million dollars of his own
money yeah based on a script he read
yeah and you know doesn't really know
what two and a half million dollars gets
him I had no idea and he just totally
rolled the dice on me wow and who is
this guy his name is Gary Gilbert and
he's become a successful um film uh
producer what an unbelievable Story how
did you know what you were doing you
never directed I went to film school and
I made short films before where did you
go to film School Northwestern
yeah that's what I wanted to do I wanted
to act and I loved acting but I really
wanted to make movies I really wanted to
make films and when I got scrubs I was
like the first thought that came to my
mind was oh this is going to help me get
my movie made and you have an amazingly
loyal fan yes I've been very clear ever
since scrubs and Garden State the two
things I'm most known for how lucky am I
wrote a play and I took it to London in
my first play and I started in London we
sold out this theater in the West End
for four months wow and it's because of
this loyal fan base that just supports
everything I do
foreign